all right let's get into the mailbag
also known as Friday feedback also known
as the Friday Feed Bag
I don't know you can email info
davidpackman.com
leave a YouTube comment send a tweet
whatever the case may be your commentary
might end up featured in this segment we
will start with William Sutherland who
suggested via a YouTube comment to my
entire audience people
go watch Jimmy Dore someone who talks
truth not this BS and you know what if
this comment resonates with you
I am not going to try to convince you
otherwise one of the things I'm actively
not going to do on the program
is try to convince people about why or
whether they should watch or listen to
me or anybody else if to you if you go
over to Jimmy dore's Channel and you say
you know it looks to me like Jimmy Dore
is telling the quote truth and David
pakman is quote lying
that's great
go watch Jimmy Dore leave me alone I'm
not gonna be offended whatsoever okay I
I would love for you to do that Marvin
whitler commented on YouTube
quote
to be a atheist you have to acknowledge
there is a God for you not to be live in
there for your wrong your not an atheist
this is painfully stupid
if I don't believe in purple unicorns
does that mean that I there must be a
purple unicorn out there somewhere for
me not to believe in it
no that doesn't make any sense
whatsoever this is the type of nonsense
that ends up becoming a meme and
repeated and repeated and repeated
and if you take one second to think
about it
you realize it doesn't make a shred of
sense whatsoever to be a atheist you
have to acknowledge there is a God
no you don't
doesn't really make any sense I'm sorry
okay Grimace posted to the subreddit
about my book recommendation waves of
rancor and says David mentioned this
book on a show last week I was able to
hunt down a copy holy cow reading this
book is eye-opening it was published in
99 and the stuff they talk about how the
far writer indoctrinated is insane they
still use the same techniques today I
highly recommend it I would buy a used
copy or find a means of getting a less
expensive digital copy this is fantastic
this really you know how it's like you
can you can get anything right now you
can find any random book
this book is genuinely tough to get I
ended up getting a used hardcover copy
looks like an old school library book I
think it might have been a library book
at some point and I didn't I didn't
remember the book was from 99 I thought
it was even older if you want to trace
how right-wing media got to where it is
today and right wing indoctrination got
to where it is today
you have to understand how it started
and this book waves of rancor goes back
to the way in which talk radio
originally ended up on AM radio the
degree to which right-wing religious
broadcasters sucked up a bunch of the
licenses for broadcasting all the way
through and into Fox News if you really
want to understand how our media got to
where it is today
such an important book and I love that
Grimace was able to uh find a copy also
from the subreddit Matt lately
says does anybody else reflexively say
truth sensual or Lauren bobert I watched
too many of his meaning my videos that
the wrong pronunciations are permanently
stuck in my head yeah the same thing
happens to me sometimes when when Trump
goes at a speech and he says they should
really be investigating Biden and
Hillary and even Obama Obama I will
sometimes almost feel like Trump got it
wrong by saying Obama instead of Obama
they are they're extraordinarily meme
worthy uh little Snippets and I
apologize if now they're in people's
heads in that way okay also from the
subreddit this is from a user named cool
customer
this gets me back to do people watch
what I watched the videos before
commenting do people listen to what I
say before commenting I recently did a
segment about Bobby Kennedy Junior's
candidacy saying this guy's an anti-vaxx
dude he's using pro-putin talking points
no one should vote for him and yes I
once had dinner with him and we have
mutual friends
look at the posts that showed up on my
subreddit David shouldn't whitewash uh
Bobby Kennedy Jr I understand there's a
personal Progressive connection there
but in my opinion David shouldn't cover
for his anti-vaccine history he didn't
become anti-vaccine during the pandemic
he's been anti-vac since 2005.
in fact he runs one of the largest
vaccine disinformation campaigns
Children's Health defense uh he's done
an inordinate amount of damage to Public
Health
um
okay so anyway the point here is did you
even listen to what I had to say I
didn't whitewash it in fact what I said
was despite the fact that this is a
little awkward because I've met Bobby
Kennedy Jr and we had dinner ones and we
have friends in common
his candidacy is a disaster he's an
unmitigated anti-vaxxer he's going on TV
he went on Tucker before Tucker was
fired and used pro-putin talking points
this is a disaster and by the way Steve
Bannon loves the idea of Bobby Kennedy
running as a quote Chaos Agent and it's
all the nonsense I didn't whitewash
anything
in fact I said despite personal
connections I think that this campaign
is an absolute and total disaster so
please
criticize me for things I've said not
things I haven't said the Bobby Kennedy
candidacy is a disaster without a doubt
okay John uh commented on YouTube just
remember the same people who want to ban
clothing they don't think is appropriate
are almost always the same people who
wanted to ban masks during a worldwide
deadly pandemic it's more about their
personal feelings over those of anyone
else yeah this goes to this idea that
um Ben Shapiro talked about the idea of
banning people from wearing clothes that
don't align with the traditional clothes
worn by their gender and I explained it
makes absolutely no sense and then the
Department of Agriculture I believe it
was in Texas we talked about it last
week is looking to put in a policy where
you have to dress in accordance with the
traditional clothing of your gen it is
you know the same people who uh talk
about how great freedom is and Liberty
and government not getting involved in
people's lives are now saying we're
going to decide what you wear they are
the same to some degree they are the
same folks that were saying um uh no
masks band masks whatever
and then going to leave the masking to a
personal choice but not the clothing
we'll decide what clothing you can wear
but leave the masking to a personal
choice these aren't serious people
that's really at the end of the day the
most important thing to understand these
are not serious individuals who bring
real thought to the table they
reflexively will say whatever they think
at that particular moment is useful to
achieve whatever immediate goal they
have even if it conflicts with whatever
they said A week ago
a user sassy Nana
asks a really great question about these
ideas of sending homeless people to
encampments outside cities for
rehabilitation of different kinds sassy
Nana says how do you rehabilitate
a homeless single mother
who works full-time at Subway but can't
afford an apartment and of course that
is an absolutely accurate critique of
this idea that Trump has about we're
going to get them seen by doctors and
psychiatrists and we're going to get get
them off drugs and all these different
things
tons of homeless people
are working or very recently were
working and either way sending them
outside of a city will either make them
unable to continue working
or make it dramatically more difficult
for them to get a job anytime soon it's
a disastrous idea the homeless
encampment idea has a recent examples of
how it's failed and more distant in
history examples of how it's failed it's
inhumane the conditions always become
ridiculously humiliatingly bad
dangerously bad and the crowd cheers
whenever Trump brings it up so it is
very very scary stuff if you have
anything you want to say feedback on the
show criticisms praise whatever you can
email info at davidpackman.com or leave
a comment on any of our various social
media platforms we have a fantastic
bonus show for you today the show
doesn't have to end right now if you're
not a member there's no more show until
next Monday if you are a member we have
the bonus show coming right up you can
sign up at joinpakman.com and make
absolute sure that you know the coupon
code indicted is available to you and I
think it's uh it's like a 50 discount
off of the cost of membership join
pacman.com see you on the bonus show